et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis gainesvile en floride avec tom
luongo économistes c'est notre rubrique
vu de l'extérieur ce soir bonsoir tob
luongo merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france on se rappelle un ce
chiffre le pétrole qui termine en baisse
de 20 5% à new york 31,13 le baril le
dollar pardon le baril est ce que ce
sont les chiffres qui vous inquiète
cela dépend à qui on parle si on parle
des associations des sociétés
américaines alors oui elles sont très
inquiète toujours et préoccupé par le
prix du pétrole sauf les consommateurs
bien sûr qu'ils vont profiter de prix de
l'énergie bien plus bas pour les
consommateurs c'est bien pour les
exportateurs c'est mal et pour
l'économie j'ai envie de vous demander
en général il ya compte les
consommateurs d'un côté bien sûr vous
l'avez dit mais l'économie en général
est ce qu'elle peut clairement pâtir de
ces chiffres inquiétants
tout à fait le problème avec une baisse
brutale des prix du pétrole c'est que le
marché sont structurées autour du prix
présente donc les contrats présents et
futurs sont basés sur ce prix et si la
marge baisse alors les contrats en
souffre beaucoup de personnes perdent
beaucoup d'argent
le problème plus important c'est pour
les producteurs de pétrole et les
répercussions pour ces personnes qui ne
peuvent pas absorber beaucoup de dettes
les personnes qui hésitaient qui ont
beaucoup de dettes ne pourront pas se
permettre de continuer de continuer à
produire avec ses prix cela aura donc
des répercussions sur les banques qui
ont prêté l'argent et cela mènera à des
effets de cascades sur le marché c'est
ce que l'on commence à observer
aujourd'hui avec la baisse des actions
les personnes essayent de d'acheter de
l'or par exemple
effectivement les bourses qui termine en
forte baisse 1 aujourd'hui
est-ce que vous en tant qu'économiste
vous avez de sérieuses inquiétudes on se
dirige tout droit vers une crise telle
qu'on l'a vécu en 2008
cette crise actuelle des racines qui
remontent à il ya six mois lorsque plus
des problèmes économiques à new york et
la réserve fédérale a dû commencer à
intervenir
la réserve fédérale a commencé à
s'ingérer et à créer une sensation
forces de sécurité nous commençons à
voir les conséquences de cela les
conditions sont présentes pour une
déflation le bal de l'activité
économique
le prix des actifs baisse également les
dépassements en dix minutes et il nous
avions juste besoin d'un moment
charnière d'un catalysateur un peu et il
faut considérer tout se voit comme une
contraction massive des actions du
dollar et c'est la cause véritablement
ce problème et cela le coz depuis six
mois nous allons voir les répercussions
de cela à l'avenir même après
fin de cette panique actuelle qui de
façon à ne pas durer longtemps mais il y
aura ensuite tunisie deuxième problème
comme nous l'avons vu en 2008 mars 2008
ya eu un profond problème et puis à
septembre
cela a eu des répercussions sur les
marchés subsidiaire et etc merci en tout
cas tom longo économistes d'avoir été
avec nous pour notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur ce soir